[Music]
why are we so obsessed with food
nutrition health food is about stories
the grand themes of life and death the
plus/minus 50-year period which is a
period of only four generations will
probably determine what happens over the
next 10,000 years and food is a number
one decisive factor most welcome to the
bell week dialogue thank you
the most what I've enjoyed is that that
you have the top brain of the world here
having really nice time in caring
thoughts about food and caring the table
and reading the swimmers I'm talking
about visual human
I think meat consumption has become a
status symbol led by the United States
unfortunately being a Nobel laureate on
stage and just listening to that
pendulum Preschoolers been really
interesting food is a wonderful entry
point you could talk about climate
change through food in a way that people
can relate to the mission people here is
amazing you know it's covering all the
distractions and Nobel laureate -
absolutely - protector against how the
supermarket is you can choose and crews
wasted space at some thinking and we get
effectives on the same problem the Nobel
week dialogue is the celebration site
part of it is dealing with very
important topic I'm pretty amazed that
Nobel took such a deep interest in food
that year and brought together such a
diverse group of mine to really have
both sides or ten sides of every problem
thanks so much we don't know about what
we eat weight comes from in helping we
can eat food save our planet
and to produce healthy diet everything
is connected when it comes to -
absolutely of spectacular experience
because this is for the first time that
I'm attending a noble with dialogue and
I'm going to cherish it for my lifetime
and absolutely looking forward to attend
the next noble retitle and I get so
badly spin Gothenburg perhaps you've
been looking forward for that
you
[Music]